okay are we ready
yeah we're are we are live okay well
this is our first time doing something
like this and i'm very excited for the
opportunity to um interview brother skeet
i'm beginning this series um starting this week
on why you are adventist why i am adventist
and so um this afternoon we're just going to
spend a few moments just interviewing you and um
just to hear how god has led you in your life
and so um if you don't mind i'd like to begin
with a word of prayer all right we'll get into the
questions okay okay let's pray eternal father in
heaven we are so thankful for technology that
makes it possible for us to come together even
though we're separated um during this time father
i believe that we're living in a very important
time in earth's history and that you desire for
us to be faithful in our relationship with you
so i pray as we discuss how you have led brother
skeet i pray that you will guide our conversation
may it be an encouragement to others and may it
draw us to be more faithful to you in your word
for we ask in jesus name amen amen so brother skee
what um the first question i have which is a very
broad question and that is how did you become a
seventh-day adventist i was a young child when my
mother heard about the sabbath i'm not clear about
the details but she found out about the sabbath
somehow my vague recollection tells me it was from
herbert w armstrong that used to be a church that
kept the sabbath many many decades ago and she
was convicted very heavily and went in search of
actually one of his churches but we had a friend
who was a seventh-day adventist so he took us to
his church and that's how i was a child so i had
no choice and i'm glad i had no choice because my
choice might have been the wrong one so that's how
i came into the church and i'm very glad that the
lord led my mother the way he did because the
church has been an immeasurable blessing to me
and so when did i guess the choice to be a
seventh-day adventist christian become your own
and how did that happen that's a good question
because everyone has to make a personal choice
you know you don't become an adventist by a family
you have to make your own you become an adventist
by family but you've got to make a choice for
jesus christ i don't have a day but very early
i realized what the church thought was right
and so i accepted it at an early age that this
is right and so i never had a conflict between
my mother's decision to take me into the church
and my personal decision they blended
perfectly but i don't have a historic date
as to when that occurred but i know
it occurred that i was quite young
okay because i always knew i should preach
even before i became a suddenly evidenced
so i guess it's a follow-up question you said that
there wasn't a conflict between what your mother
had chose and what as a young person um especially
during the teenage years and the colleges often
times where the faith becomes your own as an
individual can you share a time that you remember
when that choice became especially personal maybe
when your faith was challenged or maybe someone
um i don't know can you think of a time when um
you had to choose maybe when you were a young
young person well my faith was never really quite
challenged to be quite honest my two sisters the
faith was challenged for them because they had to
write an exam called the gce general certificate
of education when i came to right mind there
was no sabbath issue they had a sabbath issue
but they refused to write it so they were given
alternate dates so their faith was challenged
i was spared that inconvenience but i don't
recall a time when my face was challenged but i do
know that i held on to those teachings of the
church very very firmly i was in this when i was
in high school i was staying in a religion class
and the teacher was from some minister of some the
church he was a teacher and the bible says behold
he cometh with clouds and every eye shall see him
revelation 1 7. and the minister made fun of that
because i said christ is coming on the clouds of
of glory so he made fun of it and he drew a
picture on the board saying here's a little man
sitting on clouds is that what you believe so i
felt a little badly but it did not shake my belief
that's the only incident where i thought
my faith was challenged at an early age so
you would did you go to a public school then
yes i went to public school called combermere
high school by the way that's the school
rihanna attended that famous singer who's
also from my country barbados but that's where i
was it was we had morning worship every morning
it wasn't a christian school but the entire
environment of the country was christian so
all schools had morning worship regardless
of your religion so i grew up in the school
with morning worship every morning okay
and i think that's i think the beauty of
how god works in our lives is that he leads us
and sometimes we don't have a specific point or
a specific instance but we know that his presence
has always been with us right god's faithfulness
it leads me to maybe a different question is how
did um where did you go to college what was your
degree and what was your college journey and how
did god lead in that i attended oakwood college
which is now oakland university prior to that i
spent one year at west indies college which is now
i believe northern caribbean university in jamaica
but essentially my college years were at oakwood
college i did english and theology then i went
directly to the seminary and studied new testament
theology as i prepared to do a ministerial
work preaching work so oakwood and the seminary
both experiences were unforgettable okay and
so when you graduate did you go into ministry
not not uh formally i was invited in my senior
year to join a conference one of the officials
of the conference came to me because i was at the
time president of the student movement so he came
to me we sat down i talked and i told him i
don't want to do that i thank him very much
i told him i needed to be free not under
the constraints of a conference so i said no
and thanked him very very profusely and he
understood and so i've always worked independently
but i've served two conferences in
my independent self-supporting way
i've worked with two congresses michigan that
make reason with great blessing from both
so i know though at one point your journey
took you to the university of michigan
yes and so how did god lead in that and how did
god use you in that context in a second i was
working as an academic advisor at that university
of 15 years most of it in the medical school
and even while i was doing that i was
speaking because preaching is in my blood
more than anything else uh i was able to minister
while i was there to students individually
of course while i was there was also part
of campus and so that experience was very
very a great blessing to me because i had a
chance to reach out to students to faculty
i remember one phd student he's an adventist
now he'd come and talk to me every morning
very early in the morning whatever struggles
he had and i talked to him very lovely fellow
i think he now works for nih somewhere but he
got baptized and i look back on that with humble
gratitude i enjoyed my time at that university
and with campus ministries of course yes
so if you were um let's say counseling a young
person that wants god to lead in their life
they're not necessarily their degree is not
and they don't feel called to full-time active
ministry but they want to serve god how would you
direct them in being faithful as a seventh-day
adventist but finding god's will of what what
is the path to find where god would have them to
um serve in terms of a job or that sort of thing
in education page 267 paragraph three elive writes
we need to keep in mind god's plan of life to do
our best in the work that lies nearest to commit
our ways to god and to watch for the indications
of his providence now she lists three things
to do our best in the work that life whatever
you're doing now except it's criminal activity
whatever you're doing now otherwise says do your
level best because excellence is required in any
human endeavor two commit your ways to god
what are your ways your physical life your
romantic life your economic life your family life
your social life commit your professional life
commit your ways to god that has to be daily and
three she says watch for the indications of his
providence the quotation ends in a very powerful
way these are rules that ensure safe guidance
in the choice of an occupation these are rules
that ensure it's a guarantee safe guidance
in the choice or selection of an occupation so
she tells us what to do you may be in a line
of work that you do not consider god's first
choice for you but still do your best because
in any line of work we're actually working for god
that's the philosophy in ephesians 6 5-8 you see
servants be obedient to your masters according
to the flesh as antichrist we must work as if
we're working for him everything the christian
does must be a spiritual activity that's not a
fanaticism that's just biblical reality because
first corinthians 10 31 says whether therefore
ye eat or drink or whatsoever he do if you're
a preacher if you're an actuarial scientist
if you're a biologist if you're a lawyer if you
drive a bus whether therefore you eat or drink
or drive a bus or study biology do all to
the glory of god and that has no exceptions
when you live that way the guidance
of god comes into your life
but you must ask yourself also if i'm
studying geography in college how will i
use that for the glory of god how can i use that
to advance the gospel we're at the end of time
and we just can't say well i'll be honest i'll
get to work on time we must be more directly
involved in advancing the gospel because we are
at the very end of time if you're driving from
or you're walking from your home to your
house if you live in your house to your office
you walk at a certain pace if you found out that
your house is on fire you don't walk from the
office to your house you run your behavior changes
in time of crisis and so we are in a time of
crisis and so our our lifestyles to suggest that
the gospel is our priority now how an individual
does that is between the person and god but surely
we should give evidence that we truly believe
we are in the toes of the image of daniel 2 the
last days and last day living has to be different
from previous times emergency behavior is
different from behavior when life goes on as usual
when god sees the heart of a person is to do his
will he directs and of course you must also ask
god directly to guide you psalm 32 verse 8 i will
instruct the unteached in the way which thou shalt
go i will guide you with mine eyes psalm 25 4 show
me thy ways o lord teach me thy tabs lead me in
thy truth god loves to lead he demonstrated
that with the israelites he loves to lead
what he does is he goes ahead of you and finds
a place for you to pitch your tent then he leads
you to it through the path of obedience the lord
wants to leave he'll leave but we must ask him
and we must follow elevates counsel do the best in
whatever you're doing now commit your ways to god
watch for the indications of his providence
the way to watch is to keep your eye on his
word because the word will sensitize
you to the moving of god in your life
saturating our minds in our hearts yes eyes with
the word and then we recognize how god functions
how he speaks how he behaves you recognize
it by conditioning your mind with his word
so with that um in your experience have you ever
come across a young person that has struggled
with this and yes and in without sharing names or
anything like that just share what that experience
was and how it might be an encouragement to
maybe some of the others that are listening
today number one the life must belong to god and
white writes and steps to christ we are not god's
children unless we are so entirely also right
satan takes control of every mind that is not
decidedly under the control of god mind character
and personality volume 1 page 13 paragraph three
satan takes control of every mind that is not
decidedly under the control of the spirit of god
step one is to make sure your life is god's you've
given it to him then he has the right to guide and
direct that life it doesn't mean he abandons
you if your life was given to him but what god
can do for you when your life is his there is
for what he can do when your life is not his
give the life to god you ask yourself how can
i use my talents my gifts for the glory of god
you must answer that question very directly
you may have to write down your answers
in other words your mind must be in the
direction of the glory of god the work of god
and god blesses a mind like that then you
look at your gifts your talents you have
life says to every man is given his work the
work for which his capabilities adapt him
and so you look at your abilities my abilities
point me in which direction should i work
with people should i work alone should i be a
counselor should i be a minister should i be a
scientist what is my disposition and what are
my abilities you look at the two some people's
disposition is not to work with crowds it is to be
alone doing research looking at data and coming to
conclusions they love to be alone that's fine
there's nothing unbiblical or sinful about that
other people love to be in front of people well
you choose a job that corresponds with that so
you look at your this your disposition you look
at your aptitude and you look at your abilities
and then you come to some some decisions i think
that based on my abilities and my aptitude i am
best suited for this this this and that you
literally write it down then you go to god
and you say father here is what i have come up
with what do you think you see god must have the
last word and so proverbs 3 5 and 6 says trust
in the lord with all thine heart and lean not
unto thy non understanding it does not say don't
use your understanding it says don't lean on it
so when you've done that examination of yourself
that research into what you are able to do then
you say father here are my findings and the lord
can say okay change that change that go in this
direction that direction but it's a cooperative
cooperative effort between the person and god
you just don't ask god a question and sit down
with your arms folded you have to do something it
is in that doing with god's glory in mind that the
lord directs and guides and so my first advice is
give your life to god so he's working with what
is his you know ellen white writes fallen man
is satan's lawful captive it's a very frightening
statement fallen man is satan's lawful captive and
god cannot just break into satan's territory and
get you out unless you call upon him and so god
must have a legal right and that legal right is
given to him when you surrender the life to him do
you ever um you may have mentioned it but where's
the reference where fond man is control pardon
satan takes control of every mind no fallen man
is satan's lawful captain steps to christ page 17
man is satan's lawful captain i've had
some um interesting conversation recently
with some friends about the importance of
intercessory prayer because of in how prayer in
especially praying the promises that are in god's
word that god is using which appears praying for
those that are um are captive to satan that they
can the deliverance that comes through god's word
so go ahead intercessory prayer
is part of christian behavior
that's what moses did and god turned
away his wrath from the israelites
moses got between god and the israelites he
had a relationship with god so he can do that
if you don't know god don't put yourself in that
position you may regret it moses interceded to
the israelites and god is looking for people who
will stand in the breach for others pray for them
listen brave so we james 5 7 16 confess your
faults one to another and pray for one another
when job prayed for his friends god bless him
so intercessory prayer is being christ's life
because he is our great intercessor john 14 6
i am the way the truth and the life no
man cometh unto the father but by me
that man who could not walk who was let down
through the roof that was an intercessory act on
the part of his friends and jesus recognized
the faith of his friends and bless him
speaking of um you know how we're influenced
and we need to be influenced by the word
and not leaning on our own understanding
one of the areas that i think young people
are trying to figure out is um that
special someone i know some people that are
engaged or are dating um so i have an interesting
question for you brother and that is how
how did you meet your wife and that's good
and amen and how did god lead you to know
that she was the one that would be your partner
in ministry you don't know absolutely you just
know that the rights were the wrongs or maybe
that's not or the strengths are really weaknesses
by far that's what you could be sure about but
you never get a straight word from god well not
not usually yes this is the one like god hand
picked a rebecca the the the strengths must
outweigh the weaknesses the weaknesses must be the
things you will you're willing to live with but
the strengths must outweigh the weaknesses and of
course the foundation stone is of the same faith
and in your uh is it adventist home page 67
paragraph one to connect with an unbeliever is
to place yourself on satan's ground you grieve
the spirit of god and forfeit his protection
if you study genesis 6 the one iniquity sin
that is identified is mixed relationships
i'm just wondering how how did you
invite god into that process of um
simple yes it's very simple and
and it costs nothing simple prayer
because there's a way to see it right unto man
but the end thereof are the ways of death with
all your intelligence you cannot trust your own
intelligence you use it but you must not trust it
samson saw this woman i wanted her the parent
said can't you find an israelite woman sam says
she pieces me well that was his way of course it
was the way of death simple pray directs people
when eliezer went looking for a wife for eyes
of genesis 24 he prayed to god he prayed to god
and the lord directed led him god leads
but we must let him see we want to be led
prayer is indispensable and irreplaceable
when you consider being led by god and it's
encouragement that his promises says that
um you know we will be led if we want
absolutely so um let me also say this the
search for a partner should not be made a
god it's for many people is their god that's all
they think about that is idolatry that's all they
think about or to have a child or whatever
that's all and it and it gets ahead of god
thou shalt have known the gods before me i've
seen it some people they want something so
badly it becomes a god in their lives the
pursuit of a partner must not become a god
all right go ahead um so with that um in terms of
not allowing anything else to become a god before
god is what keeps your relation and i think
you've kind of touched on this already but
what keeps your relationship with god growing each
day right study the answers to these fundamental
questions are quite simple you know they're not
funny i italian logic and platonic reasoning
simple prayer is that simple it's not
rocket science or you know greek or hebrew
prayer and study and dearly surrender
there is right daily surrender
so um if you could let me say something else in
uh desire of ages 3 24 paragraph 1 elris says
without a vital connection with god through
surrender of ourselves to him moment by moment
we shall be overcome without a personal
acquaintance and a continual communion we
are at the mercy of the enemy and will do his
bidding in the end so it's a constant surrender
it's not i'm saved okay fine let me relax and
go to the beach no there's a constant battle
hebrews not hebrews galatians 5 17 for the flesh
lusteth against the spirit and the spirit against
the flesh and these are contrary one to the other
so that he cannot do the things he would it's a
constant battle the moment you accept price you've
declared war accepting price is an act of war
and you fight until you go to
the grave or you're translating
but you get stronger you get stronger with
each passing day you see you get stronger
and at some point it definitely realizes i'm
wasting time with him let me go to somebody else
can't get him i can't get him let me go
to somebody else when ruth told uh not
ruth naomi told ruth go back with your
sister ruth said and treat me not to
to leave thee or to return from following out
today with our voice i will go with our lives
i will lie like people might people like god
my people without dies i will die they will
be buried verse 18 the bible says when naomi saw
that she was steadfastly minded to go with her
she left off talking to her when she saw the
mindset of ruth she left her alone the devil
does not see in us that mindset that no matter
what he does we're not going along with him
and so he keeps bothering us but james 4
7 says resist the devil and you will flee
he must realize look i'm wasting time with him
let me find it more prof spend it more profitably
with that guy or with that lady because this
man is a is a block he's a cinder block on
this young lady there's nothing they're
like the three hebrew boys they prefer
to die then go along with my plans
for them let me go to somebody else
but satan needs to see this person is determined
to be faithful to god i try everything and i'm
it's like hitting my head against the wall i'm
sick of these headaches let me go try somebody
else but very often you see to get to that point
god must be more valuable to you in your life
because when the devil tried joke he took away his
possessions job was still faithful the devil went
back the devil said to god skin for skin all that
a man hath will he give for his life and he was
right when my life is in danger i'll turn away
from god but i'm speaking generally and satan
knows that he just has to threaten the life or
the income or the food or the physical part of a
person and people will leave god esau for the sake
of his physical survival gave up the spiritual
and so it's prayer and studies doesn't make
you perfect i'm not saying that and simply say
those are the two keys
britain's study surrender daily
like writes genuine conversion is not needed
once in years but daily daily i think it's
christ triumphant base 215 paragraph two genuine
conversion is needed not once in years but daily
and i think that's where the enemy gets us
especially you know i remember when sister wright
was speaking about public campus ministry
and selected that you know if if we're off
our guard one day the enemy will yes and
it's so impressive it's so unperceived
we don't even realize that we've placed
our feet on a path that is going to lead us
so far away from christ you know um we're going to
be opening up for questions for our participants
in a minute but i'd like to ask one final question
and that is um for yourself what does it mean for
you to be a seventh-day adventist christian
to be a seventh-day adventist christian is
to be a member of a group that god raised up to
prepare the world for the second coming of christ
a member of the group to whom god has
entrusted a message he's given to no one else
a message to prepare the world to meet christ
whether to meet him as someone saved or someone
opposed to him either way you're prepared because
if you read revelation 14 there are two harvests
both are right the harvest of the lost the harvest
of the saved and the messages of revelation 14
6-12 combined with revelation 18 1-5 they're
prepared they are the messages that bring the
world to rightness for god or against god so i
am a member of an organization that god raised
up and commissioned to preach a message that
will prepare the world for the coming of christ
when the message is properly preached and is it
is uh operationalized and those who preach it
then the glory of god is uh is what's that what
i'm looking for vindicated along with preparing
the world for the return of jesus christ advocates
have a message no one else can preach even though
it's in the bible anyone can read it the three
angels messages no one else can preach let me say
again i'm a member of an organization that is as
close to god as the israelites were in the office
god has called this church in this day as he
called this church as he called ancient israel
the same thing of course that kind of thinking
is dying out from the church this tragic
but god has called this church
today as verily as he called israel
and we have more knowledge than israel too much
is given much is required so it is a solemn
privilege solemn in the light of all we've
been given to be a member of this church
to leave this church to go
anywhere else is to step down
i don't say we're better we're different
and gotta hide holds us to
that he called us deliberately
you know we love to say and i've said it
the church was founded by eloy james white
jane andrews uriah smith john byington no no
john lesboro the church was founded by christ
but christ uses agents so does the devil by
the way the agents he used were william miller
ellen white james white jade andrews john biden
joseph bates yes he used those angels but this
seventh-day adventist church was founded by christ
is sustained by christ and will carry go through
the time of trouble by the power of christ god has
never had two special people you see he's only had
one in the bible days the israelites today said
we have risks but our mission is to reach others
you understand when god called abraham he said
and i will make the excellent i will bless you and
make thy name great and thou shalt be a blessing
i will bless them that bless thee and cursing that
curse of thee and in thee shall all families of
the earth be blessed god called abraham to be a
conduit of god's blessings to the heathen we're
called to be channels of god light god's truth
to those who don't know but just to be called
to carry that function is a tremendous honor
most advocates don't understand what it means
to be an adventist that's why so many leave the
church they don't understand it sometimes it's
not their fault maybe some of the leaders fault
because they're not people are not taught but
it is a tremendous honor to be a seventh-day
adventist as it was to be an israelite back in
the bible days and the shame the disgrace and the
embarrassment for god is that we don't see them
and so we try to live like anybody else we try to
worship like them and like them like them because
we don't understand the uniqueness of our calling
the israelites told samuel in 1st samuel 8 we
want to be like the other nations god called
them to be different from the other nations they
wanted to be like the other nations god called
us to be different from when god called abraham
uh beatrix of prophet's page 126 paragraph one
the bible says now this abraham was in
a special sense connected with heaven
he must dwell among strangers his character
must be peculiar differing from all the world
that calling is on us now do i say we're perfect
no but at least we must understand what we called
you and i think that's an invitation for god from
god to us to really not only accept that call but
um seek for the holy spirit to teach means to live
out that call yes that's expressed in his word
you know it's um even just up here in rural
michigan we've had so many people interested
in the bible people are now in the book
of revelation i think then they happen
all right and it's exciting i think by
us understanding the call that god has
placed on us especially at this time in
earth's history and during this crisis
we have an opportunity to share the three
angels message and what god's preparing to do
if it's okay could i open it up to some questions
all right okay um so i'm gonna ask
if there's any questions um let's see
go ahead um i'm not sure if there's any
questions if there are um let's see if
if the host could unmute the
others so that they could have
opportunity to talk um and
unmute their cameras as well
um
so if um anyone would like to ask a question
um just type it in the chat box then we can
unmute you that might be the easiest way to do it
um i know that we have some students
here from wayne state from ufn
there was a few others on here but i think
they had to step out because they had class
open that up if anyone had any questions i
got a question uh this is andrew park from
michigan state university i'm curious do you take
notes when you do your devotions is that like the
springboard for the messages that you give or is
your devotional time more so for just communion
with god and then you're changed anytime you
read the bible your mind is open to a message
if you're devotion or you're just reading casually
or you're memorizing you're reading ella white
anytime you interact with the bible there's a
likelihood that the seed of a message will be
planted in your mind so yes and it's during the
day as you have god's word in your head as you
think about it during the day you recite it you
think on it all kinds of messages come to you
but yes in a devotional period a message can
certainly come to you of course many come that
way i would imagine if you talk to anyone who
preaches for a living many messages come that way
but you usually like take notes or is it kind of
like you are just into devotional time and then
your knowledge grows and understanding
grows and your community i don't if it's
if a sermon idea comes to me i write down the idea
and that's it okay with the verse that went with
it and that's it but i don't take notes as such
thank you dr park um andrew park
is actually judy's cousin julian
judy ramos's cousin oh really
oh then he's a good man
he's a good man love judy love julie love
jokes so he grew people good people yeah
he grew up going to the detroit korean
church okay very good very good very good
i have a quick question yes so my name is dixon
i'm i'm out i'm i represent the wayne state
um i'm sorry i'm forgetting but i represent wayne
state all right god bless wayne state yeah yes
and i want to ask in the sense of um
i'm trying to begin meditating and um
meditating after devotional time and i kind of
want to do what do you what should meditation be
very good that's an excellent question before
i answer let me pray father in heaven grant
me wisdom as i speak to those whom you
love their god tell me what to tell them
that they may be directed to you in jesus name
i pray amen you know the bible says blessed is
the man that walketh not in the counsel of the
ungodly nor standeth in the way of sinners nor
sitteth in the seat of this country that's psalm
1 but his delight is in the law of the lord and in
his law does he meditate day and night of course
the bible says the evening in the morning with
the first day second third fourth all the way down
to the sixth meditation is absolutely essential in
order to understand god's work and to be affected
by the divine power in that word to meditate is to
put your mind you take a verse whatever that verse
may be your passage and you meditate not only when
you've concluded your devotion you meditate
during the devotion because you're thinking
you take that verse or that passage it may be
from eloise writing and you think you think to
the exclusion and everything else what is
that verse saying if we confess our sins
he is fearful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all unrighteousness
what does that mean and you'll begin to think
faithful and just those two things are there
synonyms are they different what does that mean
to cleanse me from all even if you come away with
no direct answers the very fact that you engage
your mind with god's work will bless your mind
meditation is focusing the mind like a laser beam
on god's word to the exclusion of everything else
for a while there are other distractions like
work and family and whatever else but in a moment
of true meditation you try to block out everything
else but all during the day you should also try to
meditate okay thank you so much you are very
welcome let me add this here's another way
to meditate wherever you go there's
evidence of god the bible says in
psalm 19 1 the heavens declare the glory
of god so at night wherever you look
up you can see god's glory if you're honest
you see uh you see design you see beauty
you see reliability you see law because certain
starts the same place every night now during the
day isaiah 6 3 the whole earth is full of his
glory the glory of god is the character of god
which means day and night up and down you're
surrounded by evidence of god so if you're driving
you see a tree it was made on the third day
you think about that you thank god for the
tree you're driving down the road there's a dead
animal roadkill the wages of sin is death for
man and for animals you think of that and you
along for that world where there'll be no death
you know you put on your clothes the cotton came
from a plant the trees were made by god everything
you see should point your mind towards god so
that your life becomes a daily experience of
devotion at various levels of intensity with god
you know everyone tells us creation was designed
to keep our minds on god all the time without a
break and so there's this this this concept of
constant meditation by just observing you look at
the sky it was made on the second day you look at
you know your shoe made from leather cows made on
the sixth day a car there's metal in it the metal
came from the earth earth was made separated from
the water on this on this on the third day you
look at all these things and you make a spiritual
connection by so doing your mind is on god all day
of course it's a habit you must train your mind
to think like that you see grass you think of god
you see death you think of god you see a human
being you think of god they were made on the
sixth day and so that's a way to live a life of
active meditation i call that active meditation
in addition to that concentrated time when you're
in the word of god nothing else gets into your
mind i hope i didn't say too much at that point of
meditation i mean thank you so much uh i actually
have to go to class right now well god bless you
now in class look for god in the subject matter
all knowledge is from god proverbs 1 verse 7 the
fear of the lord is the beginning of knowledge do
you look for god in your subject matter regardless
of the subject unless it is crime look for god in
your subject matter i definitely will thank
you so much all right have a nice day guys
i have a quick question as well so i my name is
kelly my name my name is kelly and i'm from the
university of michigan uh god bless the wolverines
all right uh my question is what techniques do you
use to memorize scripture and spirit of prophecy
all right simple mind character and personality
volume one pitch six so volume two plays 601
paragraph four that which at first seems difficult
by constant repetition grows easy and right
thoughts and actions become habitual what i do
is constant constant constant constant repetition
i'm right now working on romans chapter 10 because
it is such an important chapter when discussing
righteousness by faith it is all the time when
i'm driving in a bathroom and i'm in the gym all
the time you're rehearsing god's word in your mind
but constant constant practice i should say is
the key there's no easy way there's no osmosis
that allows you to do that you must apply yourself
to it i recommend for these one you must have a
desire the desire is based on whether you see
the value in doing it if you see no value you
will have no desire two you must be determined
the shortest verse of the bible is john 11 35
jesus swept if it takes you six months to get
that you stick with it that's determination
d number three discipline if it's raining you
try if if there's a flood you try if there's an
earthquake you try if there's world war three you
still do it that's this discipline discipline says
i don't care what's going on i have this duty to
perform and number four divine power ask god to
help you because you're dealing with a divine a
divine entity the word of god you ask him because
the carnal mind does not naturally understand
god's word and has no interest in god's word so
you need power from above to enable your mind to
seize on god's word hold on to it and be blessed
by it and so desire uh determination discipline
divine power and of course i love doing it when
you love doing something it ceases to be a hassle
it becomes a i just love to do it use the king
james version try it you'll be surprised how god
will bless your efforts you really will and then
you have it in your head there weren't have i hid
in my heart that i might not sit against thee uh
you you can think about it during the day you can
dwell on it by the way let me uh you all in school
christ object lessons page 125 paragraph three
if the follower of christ will believe his word
and practice it there is no science in the natural
world you will not be able to grasp and appreciate
so if you're having trouble with history with
histology pharmacology biology whatever it is
if the follower of christ will believe his word
and practice it there is no science in the natural
world you will not be able to grasp meaning you
understand it and appreciate connected to god
so god bless you if you try to memorize start
small it starts in the book of john chapter 14
let not your heart be troubled you
believe in god believe also in me
do the first three verses see what happens
god bless you in your studies what are you
studying in school what do i study yes yes i
study fluent performance and music theory what
performance flute flute performance and music
theory god invented music use it for his glory god
bless you god bless you thank you you're welcome
who's next
there any other questions
okay all right the chat just to make sure
there's any questions there i don't see any there
i have one more question go ahead yes not good you
do you uh when it comes to what you read is it do
you stick strictly with bible spirit or prophecy
or do you read other books as well oh i do i do
read other books as well or i you know read on the
internet other sources of material like history
um you have to know history to understand
prophecy history is property fulfilled so
you read history but my major reading is the
bible in our life and the pioneers those three
hello the bible hello the pioneers but if i
read others i like to read science books to see
god's fingerprints and science how can i
apply silence to god because if god created it
you know all artists leave their mark you can
tell the painting by pablo picasso you can tell
the painting by monday you can tell music by
mozart you can tell this is a musical piece by
whomever this is god's word and you can see god's
fingerprints if i may say that in creation in
his footprints in all of creation if you made
the trees then you can look for god in botany
if you made you know animals look for god
in zoology if you made yourself look for god
in ichthyology the fish you look for god
in everything except sin he's not in sin
when you look for god that way it
is not the pursuit of a grave now
it's a pursuit of the knowledge of
your savior and the great will come
because god loves hard work whatsoever
i had funny to do do it with my might
so yes you are you look for god in all branches of
knowledge every brand actually alois writes there
is no branch of the digital business for which
the word of god does not afford an essential
preparation no branch of his legitimate business
for which the word of god does not provide an
essential preparation the word of god does
the same thing for every branch of learning
except sin where is the reference for that
one legitimate business i think it'll look
the cha i think it's chapter 15 education the
chapter that deals with business principles okay
if someone has access to the writings right there
check that check that i think it's the very first
paragraph of that chapter chapter 15 i think it's
business principles that's the name of the chapter
it's something i'm hearing a lot and i highly
recommend anyone that's on this is um go back
and read the book education there's so many
practical principles yes and steps to christ
okay someone asked me yesterday if you could only
have three books by ellen white what will they be
i said steps to christ to know how to come
to christ these are adventures know who he
is great controversies know what's coming
and how to get ready those are my three
okay i have i have one question
all right and that is um
you your schedule obviously right now with
covet you're not traveling right right um
but before that i know that your schedule
was very busy in terms of traveling and
um what do you do to keep that consistent life
even though your family time differences why yes
traveling traveling means traveling use long hours
on planes let's say i'm flying from detroit to uh
melbourne that's 14 hours that's 14 hours
to either sleep or read the bible read on a
white on your phone to prepare some sermons
while you're there there is no circumstance
that can keep you from engaging in devotional
work now some some some environments are more
distracting than others yes but despite
the travel you can use the travel time
to apply yourself to the word of god now when
i get to where i'm going i only go three places
the pulpit my room and the gym i don't sightsee i
don't do these things that's where you can find me
and so i make sure i have my time for the word of
god because without that then there's no point in
getting into a booklet i'm not in the pulpit to
give speeches i'm there to preach to do that you
must have the word of god much more than you need
so it's constant constant constant in the word yes
have you had any interesting experiences of
sharing your faith when you've gone to the gym
in the gym
not as we would think of it i
there's a community gym in my town
it's a washdown community and a lot of all
the people who are there i go there sometimes
and for some reason all the guys when
they see me exercising they come to me
they say uh what are you doing this this so they
talk to me i just talk back to them i don't that
may not come across as big witnessing but as i
talked to him i'm praying he said father help me
to say the right thing to this man or this lady
they may ask questions what is exercise for and
so sometimes i usually go there from time to time
just for that reason because for some reason they
come and talk to me when i exercise i stay out
of people's business i just focus on my exercise
but they ask me questions and i i respond
there's a fellow in my gym where i'm a member
he uh we talk a lot every time i see a very
nice fellow i don't discuss religion and i'm
allowing the lord to create that opportunity
i'm just nice to him genuinely and he's very
nice to me very nice fellow young guy and so
we have that so i pray about that i say lord
at your appointed time in your own way in your
creative way bring about some interaction that
will allow this young man to come to jesus christ
and i'll leave it at that i don't preach to people
except when i'm in the pool when
god calls you to preach that's right
okay i think we're at the end of our okay any
longer i'll have to pick up an offering so it's
time to close i just want to make sure there's no
final questions from okay and then i'd like you
to pray for us would you yes i will yes i will
are there any final questions from anyone here
okay all right any hands raised so would you pray
for us yes i'll do that right now father in heaven
we thank you lord for modern technology and the
good side of it we can use to advance your work
thank you lord for the commitment you've placed
in the heart of sister elena to do this work
that's what the grady that's all the students
who tuned in who asked questions father
guide them in their studies keep them close to
your bosom their god you know how these secular
canvases are help us fathers do all we can to
advance the truth we thank you for these trying
times trying times draws closer to you bless all
of us bless our families father and may we be
the reason why others come to know you i pray
when you come save us their god in jesus name
i pray amen amen all right sister lena god
bless you brother grady blessings upon you
thank you thank you so much you guys have
a wonderful day god bless you thank you
hope we didn't disturb